verdad una nueva constitución en la que
trabaja actualmente que él espera lo
ayude a mantenerse en el poder dios
gracias de nuevo por acompañarnos en la
emisión de este reportaje recuerde que
puede ingresar a nuestra página web tras
24 punto com para ver esta emisión y las
anteriores hasta la próxima semana
al devolver a panamá en 1999 la
soberanía sobre el canal que habían
construido los estadounidenses también
les devolvieron la zona una franja de
tierra a ambos lados del canal que
estuvo habitada durante cerca de un
siglo por estadounidense 'wall 6 era
como un pequeño país artificial
construido y dirigido por ingenieros a
pesar de la salida de los
estadounidenses algunas tradiciones se
han mantenido pero también recuerdos a
veces amargos para los panameños pero
nos está acostumbrando a ir a los
tiroteo en la huella de las bombas los
niños del canal favorito de vuelta a
panamá esta semana déjalo por france 24
y france 24 puntocom
[Música]
i
ah
[Música]
nada
ah
[Música]
i
y
[Música]
a
ah
[Música]
y
crisis en jordania por un supuesto
intento de golpe el ex príncipe heredero
hamza bin husein estaría bajo arresto
domiciliario pero niegan un complot
contra su medio hermano el rey abdalá
segundo tras reunirse con líderes
tribales y criticar el gobierno los
países de medio oriente expresaron su
apoyo al rey
en brasil se autorizaron cultos y misas
en medio de plena pandemia al considerar
la actividad religiosa como esencial
pero el país rosso en las últimas horas
las 2.000 muertes
chile en mega confinamiento registró más
de 8 mil casos y en argentina una prueba
pcr confirmó que el presidente alberto
fernández tiene kobe 19
enfrentamientos y detenciones en
protestas contra las medidas como vida
han marcado las calles de varias
ciudades europeas aunque en su mayoría
han sido pacíficas mientras el
continente vive una tercera ola de la
pandemia que ha provocado un preocupante
aumento de contagios
volvemos con ustedes para actualizar la
información más importante de américa
latina y del mundo iniciamos el
informativo en jordania las autoridades
arrestaron este sábado al ex príncipe
heredero y medio hermano del rey hamza
bin husein por una supuesta intentona de
golpe también fue detenido el ex asesor
del rey jordano abdalá segundo y un
número indeterminado de personas la
agencia estatal de noticias petra
justificó razones de seguridad y amenaza
a la estabilidad del país el medio
hermano del rey confirmó en un vídeo su
arresto domiciliario y acusó el sistema
en el poder del país de incompetencia y
corrupción los países de medio oriente y
eeuu expresaron su apoyo al reino
es una disputa familiar en lo más alto
del estado jordano el ex príncipe
heredero hansa y medio hermano del rey
abdalá segundo está bajo arresto
domiciliario desde el sábado por la
noche o esto es en todo caso lo que
revela el príncipe hamza en un vídeo a
matthew retransmitido por la bbc en el
que comenta su encuentro con el jefe del
estado mayor del ejército han detenido a
algunos de mis familiares y amigos han
destituido a mi personal de seguridad y
han cortado mis líneas telefónicas y de
internet como le expliqué al jefe de
gabinete no soy responsable del
deterioro de la gobernanza la corrupción
y la incompetencia de las autoridades de
los últimos 20 años
estas críticas públicas hacia el poder
de un alto miembro de la familia real
son inéditas en la historia reciente del
país según revelaciones del 'washington
post'
el príncipe hamza ha sido puesto bajo
vigilancia tras el descubrimiento de un
vasto complot para derrocar al rey
abdalá segundo está acusado de haber
criticado abiertamente a las
instituciones durante varias reuniones
con líderes tribales el medio hermano
del soberano niega formalmente estos
vientos la situación sigue siendo
confusa el ejército que niega el arresto
de hansa dio explicaciones en un
comunicado emitido por la televisión
estatal jordana bolivia - un tabaco
fantasea ha solicitado el príncipe hans
a que cese sus actividades que puedan
afectar a la seguridad y la estabilidad
de jordania en el marco de las
investigaciones de los organismos de
seguridad se detuvo a hassan bin zeid
vashem awadallah y otras personas hasan
ben said varios altos funcionarios han
sido señalados entre ellos el
controvertido vashem awadallah conocido
por haber sido jefe de gabinete de
abdalá segundo en 2006 y jefe de la
corte real en 2007 se trata de una
maniobra crucial que llega justo una
semana antes de las celebraciones del
centenario del reino
en noticias de kobe 19 américa latina
registró más de 25 millones de casos y
ahora si continúa siendo la nación más
afectada el tribunal supremo autorizó la
realización de cultos y misa hace pese a
que el virus ha dejado una media de 2
mil 800 muertes al día en chile aunque
más del 80% de la población está
confinada los casos diarios volvieron a
superar los 8.000
continúa siendo el epicentro mundial de
la pandemia y su situación cada vez es
más crítica en las últimas 24 horas
brasil superó los 330 mil muertos por
ccoo y 19 sin embargo en el momento más
difícil de la pandemia para esa nación
la justicia autorizó la realización de
cultos y misas en todo el territorio
este sábado el ex presidente luiz inácio
lula da silva que en días pasados acusó
al presidente ya ir bolsonaro de ser
responsable del peor genocidio del país
recibió la segunda dosis de su vacuna e
hizo un nuevo llamado al gobierno
solo tiene que hacer una cosa escuchar
la ciencia a aquellos que saben y
cumplir las determinaciones
y cumplía desde una salsa
por su parte chile continúa en medio de
la llamada mega cuarentena que mantiene
confinada a más del 83 por ciento de la
población pese a las medidas y a la
avanzada campaña de vacunación que vive
el país y que ha permitido inocular a
cerca de 7 millones de personas el
sábado en la nación superó por segundo
día consecutivo la barrera de los 8000
positivos este lunes inicia el cierre de
fronteras que durará al menos hasta el
final de abril la vacuna se transforma
en una alternativa de salida a este gran
problema pero también se transforma en
la causa de otro problema es decir esta
comunicación tan triunfalista respecto
de que somos el país que más rápido
vacuna que somos felicitado
internacionalmente que vamos a lograr la
inmunidad primero que nadie mandó una
señal a las personas respecto de un
cierto relajo entretanto argentina
recibió con sorpresa la noticia del
contagio del presidente alberto
fernández a quien se le aplicaron las
dos dosis de la vacuna rusa sputnik de
en principio el jefe de estado dio
positivo a un test de antígeno y el
resultado fue confirmado por una prueba
pcr de acuerdo con la información
oficial
se encuentra estable y es asintomático
en perú siete médicos contrajeron el
virus después de haberse vacunado tres
de ellos que sólo habían recibido la
primera dosis permanecen hospitalizados
en unidades de cuidados intensivos en el
país han fallecido 401 doctores y otros
60 permanecen en las suvs y según datos
finales de marzo
sumado a esto ayer perú batió su propio
récord de muertes diarias al reportar de
294 fallecidos el territorio andino
enfrenta desde diciembre la segunda ola
de la pandemia y el jueves registró un
récord de casi 13.000 positivos
por toda europa manifestantes de
izquierda y de derecha se están
revelando contra las restricciones para
contener el avance de coronavirus
mientras el continente vive una tercera
ola de la pandemia que ha provocado un
preocupante aumento de contagios en su
mayoría se trata de manifestaciones
pacíficas pero algunas movilizaciones
han terminado en altercados con la
policía
mientras el confinamiento en europa se
alarga las protestas se extendieron de
nuevo por las calles el sábado hubo
manifestaciones contra las restricciones
por el cob y 19 en georgia rumania
alemania y suiza en bucarest la capital
rumana los manifestantes salieron a la
calle por séptimo día consecutivo para
mostrar su rechazo a las nuevas
regulaciones que incluyen un 'toque de
queda' a las 8 de la tarde
[Música]
no estamos protestando contra el virus o
contra una evidencia médica protestamos
contra las restricciones a nuestras
libertades las restricciones y las
medidas no deberían seguir siendo
obligatorias
entretanto miles de personas marcharon a
la ciudad alemana de stuttgart para
mostrar su descontento con el manejo
gubernamental de la pandemia sólo unos
pocos participantes llevaban tapabocas o
mantenían la distancia de seguridad como
requieren las autoridades un tifus te
dice más que ustedes están ustedes
penalizamos y hacemos seguimiento de las
violaciones de las reglas contra el
coronavirus pero no tomamos acciones
severas contra manifestantes reunidos de
forma pacífica de louis de un dice
jugando un show la ondulación en la
ciudad suiza de sant golem sin embargo
las protestas y desembocaron en
violencia grupos de jóvenes atacaron a
la policía con artefactos caseros
y esto respondieron con gas lacrimógeno
y balas de goma 19 personas fueron
detenidas pero ya han sido liberadas las
protestas a lo largo de europa tienen
lugar en medio de un aumento de los
contagios por coronavirus mientras las
vacunaciones siguen estancadas en las
primeras fases para analizar esta
información nos acompaña desde españa el
médico daniel lópez acuña epidemiólogo y
exdirector desde el departamento de
acción sanitaria en situación de crisis
de la organización mundial de la salud
gracias a usted por estar con nosotros y
quiero comenzar preguntándole y hartos
de los confinamientos muchos están
saliendo a protestar a las calles qué
consecuencias para la salud pueden traer
realmente estas manifestaciones en las
que incluso pues muchas personas acuden
acuden eh sin medidas de protección
con estas manifestaciones son
verdaderamente absurdas y sumamente
negativas para el control de la pandemia
recordemos que en buena parte de europa
estamos ante repuntes considerables que
constituyen ya la cuarta ola de la
pandemia es el caso de españa- pero es
el caso de muchos otros países europeos
la situación francesa es extrema de más
de 700 casos por 100.000 habitantes
italia tiene más de 500 casos por
100.000 habitantes
holanda en los países bajos y bélgica
tienen una incidencia de más de 450 y la
propia alemania de más de 250 españa por
fortuna está en una incidencia media de
150 menor que estos otros países pero
con algunas comunidades autónomas como
madrid el país vasco o navarra ceuta
melilla con incidencias de más de 250
pensar que es absurdo tener
restricciones como se manifiesta en
estas personas que además lo hacen sin
mascarillas sin protección
la mente negacionista y por otro lado
profundamente dañino para el tema del
control de la transmisión no se están
respetando las las medidas restrictivas
que tienen que ponerse en marcha para
poder frenar una incidencia tan alta
como la que estamos doctores y en medio
de este creciente número de contagios de
esta incidencia de la que usted nos
habla que atraviesa europa en esta
tercera y hasta cuarta ola y con
vacunación estancada usted cree que los
confinamientos a estas alturas si son
efectivos
bueno en situaciones como la que se ha
llegado en francia o en o en italia no
hay duda de que hay que llegar a medidas
más extremas que implican un
confinamiento un confinamiento severo
como el del principio la pandemia o un
confinamiento light no basta con las
medidas de un toque de queda suave con
restricciones de la actividad en
horarios nocturnos no basta con los
confinamientos perimetrales como los que
se hacen en españa para que no se las
personas no viajen una comunidad
autónoma a otra hay que instrumentar
medidas severas de restricción de
actividades gregarias en espacios
interiores
mal ventilados en gimnasios en bares en
locales de restauración en donde no se
garantiza una ventilación adecuada
recordemos que lo único que nos va a
permitir frenar en estos momentos la
expansión de la pandemia son
y los límites a la movilidad y los
límites que establezcan las
restricciones para poder tener una
acción libre de contagio la vacunación
todavía no nos alcanza para frenar estas
zonas tenemos que seguir avanzando a
toda velocidad pero todavía nos faltan
meses para lograr los niveles de
vacunación que nos permitan realmente
detener este abad y doctor muy
brevemente todos esos problemas que
tenemos ahora con repuntes es porque la
gente está dejando de creer en la
evidencia médica
hombre yo creo que ese es un factor que
está contribuyendo ahí hay un conjunto
de factores la fatiga pandémica el hecho
de que la gente resiste menos las
medidas restrictivas el el descreimiento
con respecto a las medidas y a la
evidencia científica y la confusión que
genera una información no sustentada en
bases científicas yo creo que tenemos
que entender que estamos en un momento
en donde todavía hay que hacer
sacrificios ministros podemos vacunar a
más personas gracias al ser pues valiosa
información y varios de los más
importantes reyes y reinas que
gobernaron egipto hace tres mil años
fueron protagonistas este sábado de un
desfile de dorado veamos
uno a uno los monarcas más antiguos de
egipto rodearon la plaza tahrir en una
extravagante muestra del rico patrimonio
del país 22 momias reales fueron
transportadas desde el museo egipcio
donde habían recibido durante más de un
siglo a su nueva residencia de descanso
en el museo nacional de la civilización
egipcia hemos elegido el museo de la
civilización porque queremos por primera
vez exponer las momias de forma
civilizada de forma educada y no para
divertirse como se hacía en el museo
egipcio el convoy del desfile dorado
constaba de 18 faraones y 4 reinas la
mayoría pertenecían al antiguo reino
nuevo que gobernó egipto entre el año
1500 39 antes de cristo y el año 1000 75
antes de cristo- con una banda militar
bailarines y guardias a caballo el
desfile se caracterizó por la pompa y la
fastuosidad a los que estas figuras
estuvieron alguna vez acostumbradas y
viajaron con estilo en vehículos hechos
a medida cada uno de ellos fue
transportado en un contenedor especial
de
era controlada para garantizar que los
antiguos miembros de la realeza pudieran
soportar el viaje de una hora hasta su
nuevo hogar sé que tendré está o segundo
el valiente que reinó en el sur de
egipto en el año 1600 antes de cristo-
encabezaba la flota la procesión también
incluye a ramsés segundo uno de los
faraones más famosos del país
la reina hachepsut también se desplazó
en su época superó las barreras de
género para convertirse en una de las
pocas faraones de egipto las autoridades
esperan que el espectacular desfile y
retransmitido en directo in sufre un
nuevo impulso a la industria turística
un sector que se ha visto paralizado por
la pandemia
fin del informativo y feliz mañana de
domingo
[Música]